[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station milliards ou
la station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands types de
l'actualité de ce mardi 11 mai la
tension ne retombe pas au proche orient
après une nuit de violences barrage de
roquettes du hamas d'un côté frappe
meurtrière d'israel de l'autre c'est le
sens de familles palestiniennes menacés
d'éviction par des colons juifs dans un
quartier de jérusalem est qui a
déclenché des heurts ayant fait plus de
500 blessés ces derniers jours ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face durant
quelques instants en russie au moins
neuf morts confirmés et une trentaine de
blessés à 15 ans après une fusillade ce
matin dans une école la plus grave
depuis 2018 dans le pays
le tireur présumé un adolescent a été
interpellé le kremlin exprime sa grande
tristesse et en donne un passage en
revue des règles autorisant le port
d'armes en russie
[Musique]
l'italie confrontée à un nouvel afflux
sur les côtes avec 2000 migrants ces
derniers jours sur la petite île de
lampedusa la droite nationaliste appelle
le président du conseil mario draghi à
réagir au plus vite face à cet afflux
soudain une nouvelle crise migratoire
juguler pour un pays affaibli par la
crise du coc vide traditionnel discours
du trône au royaume uni la priorité du
programme législatif de provisions sonne
le redressement national après la
pandémie le premier ministre en position
de force après le succès de son parti
dans les urnes mais qui devra également
composer avec la majorité
indépendantiste au parlement écossais
qui réclament un nouveau référendum
d'autodétermination
[Musique]
cinquième jour de tension donc au proche
orient où israël annonce vouloir
intensifier ses frappes et seront
représailles après la mort de deux
isrélienne ashkelon suite à des tirs de
roquettes en provenance de la bande de
gaza où 26 personnes sont mortes depuis
lundi soir selon le dernier bilan du
ministère local de la santé pour plus de
précisions nous retrouvons tout de suite
paul à slayer journalistes pour interner
un terreau t1 tard nationale bonsoir
cola vous êtes donc aux portes de damas
à jérusalem a est hot quels sont les
derniers développements au cours de la
dernière demi heure le bâtiment de m
adria et et asma defra israël là où je
vous tiens la situation est calme il y a
une présence policière très forte tout
comme au cours des cinq à neuf jours
pour le moment en tout cas aucun heurt
on dirait bien qu'il n'y aura pas de
conflit ici mais qui pourrait le voir
ailleurs le premier se serait évanoui en
état n'y arrive pas à annoncer cet
après-midi ou venant très haut et l
ennui l'intensité et la fréquence des
attaques contre la bande de gaza il a
déclaré qu'il s'attendait à ce que les
combats durent encore pendants plusieurs
juniors
il a déclaré qu'ils ont des informations
spécifiques et si des terroristes
lesquelles des victimes et sein de la
population civile
et voici l'explication est pourtant des
civils tués puis ici palestine 26
personnes à gaza ont été tués
le combat genzyme est posée la cause
plusieurs centaines de blessés du côté
palestinien
écoutez de roquettes tirés par un drone
ont touché le toit de ma maison
10 15 minutes plus tard la caserne à
côté de chez nous a été touché alors que
l'armée israélienne était encore en
train de me parler au téléphone il ne
voulait pas raccrocher temps que leur
mission n'était pas terminée après avoir
fini de bombardé la caserne
ils m'ont dit de rentrer chez moi je
leur ai demandé s'ils allaient visait ma
maison ils m'ont dit un peu et ils ont
touché le thorax aux jouets dans une rue
à l'est de la maison ils ont été
bombardées alors qu'il jouait ils
étaient tous jeunes
il avait 16 ans les hôtesses les plus
jeunes ou plus âgés c'est la quatrième
fois que l'idée serait bien nous
attaquent et tuent nos enfants
ou allons nous aller nous allons
attaquer les israéliens dans leurs
colonies
nous les femmes en premier avant les
hommes les sirènes résonnent de manière
intermittente qui tout au cours de la
journée
israël a commencé de les premiers décès
deux femmes
il lui sera l ouis ont atteint 300
roquettes ont été tirées vers israël
depuis lundi le groupe dirigeant la
bande de gaza a déclaré qu'il viserait
tel aviv le qu'il devrait y avoir une
escale à sion alors même que la
mitrailleuse
appelé samedi les soldats israéliens de
réserve ils sont en attente
quand vous en avez besoin de faire
attention des montante dans différentes
six arabes israéliens paul a évidemment
les réactions sont nombreuses
beaucoup craignent une escalade de cette
violence quelles sont les réactions
internationales du monde entier la ligue
arabe a analysé les moyens d'urgence
ministre égyptien des affaires
étrangères a déclaré qu'il avait
contacté le gouvernement israélien avec
les rencontres et pas beaucoup
d'indifférence
il est responsable de cette dangereuse
escalade département d'état américain a
critiqué le hamas pour ses tirs de
roquettes vers israël
autre élément du parlement a critiqué
ils seraient des personnes qui faisaient
force excessive et injustifiée demander
d'autres pays tels que la turquie et
l'iran condamne israël la mistral pour
cette escalade
nous avons également entendu le
ministère des affaires étrangères
français inciter à la retenue et
souhaité un retour car dès que possible
merci beaucoup paul ailleurs journaliste
pour arte internationale en direct de
jérusalem
est ce ce tome est depuis le début de
ces temps sur vendredi les
manifestations de soutien aux
palestiniens à travers le monde
multiplie tour d'horizon en images
[Musique]
en ce moment le pays d'occupation qui
est israël utilise ses forces et ses
colons pourra expulser les palestiniens
de leurs maisons et les mettre à la rue
alors pourquoi est-ce que le monde garde
le silence à ce sujet nous demandons au
gouvernement du canada de cesser de
soutenir l'armée israélienne de cesser
de soutenir l'épuration qui a lieu en
palestine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous manifestons maintenant contre les
massacres raciste qui sont commis contre
le peuple palestinien et en soutien aux
jeunes d'al aqsa et du quartier de
sheikh jarrah et d'autre de jérusalem à
jaffa haïfa
nous voulions simplement envoyer un
message en tant que jeune homme libanais
et arabes pour dire que nous essayons
autant que possible d'être solidaires de
nos frères dans mon élément
[Rires]
non
aujourd'hui la communauté internationale
craint une surenchère de violence dans
la région jusqu où vont aller ces
erreurs va-t-on vers une nouvelle guerre
à gaza c'est l'objet de notre face à
face et pour en débattre nous sommes
avec un jacques benillouche journaliste
indépendant à ses côtés gilles devers
avocat au barreau de lyon spécialiste en
droit international bonsoir messieurs
merci d'être en direct sur rt france
aujourd'hui évidemment chacun se renvoie
la balle comme à chaque fois d'ailleurs
quand ces conflits éclatent
quelle est la réalité du terrain selon
vous jacques benillouche aujourd'hui ce
que je voulais vous dire c'est que il y
a déjà dix minutes ça fait 3 1 mais ce
que nous recevons nouveau cathy la leyre
la dernière vient de sauter il ya une
minute je suis en train de vous parler
alors qu'elles sont encore c'est à dire
que nous avons le risque de recevoir des
missiles aujourd'hui j'ai entendu donc
tout à l'heure plusieurs détonations
on nous a assuré que c'était le dôme de
fer qui intervenaient et donc
effectivement on n'a pas été touché pour
l'instant mais le risque existe
n'envoyez qu'en plein je dirais qu'en
plein direct vous vivez la situation que
nous vivons
trois alertes en même pas cinq minutes
quand je faisais les tests avec votre
technicien j'ai eu la première heure
ceux ci c'est pour dire la situation que
nous vivons aujourd'hui
alors vous comprendrez que ça peut
passer c'est le détail peuvent être
beaucoup plus important que tout ce dont
on va parler et pour lesquels nous
allons essayer de deux d'être clair et
d'apporter une réponse si possible
neutre je vous laisse la parole monsieur
et je reprendrai après parce que je suis
dans une période de tension suite à la
lettre qu'ils aient lieu à l'heure
actuelle c'est un bon ben on entend les
bombardements allez-y alors gilles
devers a on le disait et avocats et dont
spécialiste en droit international parce
qu'il est beaucoup question de droit
évidemment dans ce dossier et c'est
toujours compliqué
selon point de vue où l'on se place
ce qui a mis le feu aux poudres en
l'occurrence cette fois ci c'est
notamment le sort des familles
palestiniennes menacé d'éviction à
jérusalem
il a eu ce report de l'audience clés
prévus dimanche au dernier sur ce sort
de ces familles gilles devers on
rappelle qu'en début d'année le tribunal
de district de jérusalem avait rendu une
décision favorable à ces familles juives
qui revendiqua on le rappelle d'aider
des droits de propriété dans le quartier
de cheikh jarrah secteur palestinien
occupé et annexé par israël selon un
point de vue toujours qu'en est-il au
niveau du droit
j'ai très bien je vais vous répondre
avec le plus de précision en dix ans qui
vit thomas mann interlocuteur moi je
n'ai pas les bombes donc je suis plus
serein mais ça n'empêche pas d'avoir là
le devoir de traiter les questions voilà
bon je dire également que je suis pas
neutre sur ce sujet vu que j'interviens
pour nombre de palestiniens de gaza et
de jérusalem-est de cisjordanie pour les
réfugiés je suis un avocat des
palestiniens notamment devant la cour
pénale internationale
et ça fait maintenant douze ans qu'il me
demande d'appliquer le droit en tant que
technique leur situation d'apporter
cette précision puisque voilà vous êtes
effectivement dans un face à face avec
deux points de vue
différents et c'est bien le but de ce
débat dont je vous laisse poursuivre
voilà donc moi je suis pas de jets pas
d'adversaire qu'on soit bien d'accord et
je suis très content de rencontrer
monsieur mais c'est vrai que je défends
un certain point de vue
bon on parle de droits alors pour aller
à l'essentiel
vous évoquez cette décision du district
très bien très bien elles existent moi
je vais en parler d'une autre que j'ai
amené ici un bon on va voir faire c'est
là une décision de la cour pénale
internationale
elle date du 5 février 2021
et qu'est ce qu'elle vit cette cette
décision l ai dit que la palestine est
un état et elle dit que le peuple
souverain et le peuple palestinien et
souverain sur gaza sur la cisjordanie et
sur jérusalem est dans les frontières de
donc là je donne pas mon point de vue je
donne un état de droit et c'est état de
droit il n'est pas jugé par une
juridiction locale
il est jugé par une juridiction
internationale les israéliens ont
participé à ce débat y avait le barreau
d'israël événements de personnalités qui
ont participé à ce débat juridique moi
j'ai participé au nom de victimes
palestiniens en étant quand c'est donc
affronter juridiquement mais c'est votre
thèse qui a perdu par la vôtre monsieur
mais c'est la thèse israélienne qui a
perdu vu que l'état de palestine est
reconnue avec une souveraineté sur les
territoires vous quand vous parlez de la
situation allait de sheikh jarrah et de
ce tribunal ou moi je vous dis le débat
a changé de nature et il va falloir que
les juges s'en rende compte aussi parce
que ils n'ont plus compétence la cour a
tranché 1967 s'opposent en droit
international et un juge israélien gère
les affaires à l'intérieur d'israël mais
il n'a pas compétence pour juger des
affaires sur jérusalem occupée qui fait
partie de l'état de palestine selon le
droit international
donc il ya tout un travail qui est à
faire il faut remonter toutes les
situations mais que ce soit pour la
situation de ces personnes
où que ce soit pour les bombardements
qui ont lieu sur gaza mais également les
tirs qui viennent de la résistance armée
eh bien il se trouve que le gala
palestine de tout tout tout tendances
politiques confondues avaient donné
accor et accepte le travail de la cpi
est d'accord pour travailler sur le
droit international
alors qu'après l'arrêt du 5 février
l'israël a dit qu'il ne participerait
pas donc nous sommes du côté du droit
international et en défendant les unes
palestinien je défends le droit et je
suis très à l'aise dans une émission
jacques benillouche quelle est la
position d'israël sur ce point on parle
pas forcément de la vôtre mais mais mais
discrète sur ce point puisque monsieur
devers nous dit voilà c'est le droit
international la cour aux pédales oro
international a jugé est-ce que cela
fait foi aux yeux de l'état hébreu est
également je vais vous dire que le
tribunal de ces pays n'a aucune valeur
aux israël n'est pas reconnue par les
américains
israël ne reconnaît pas ce que ce ce
tribunal qui n'a aucune aucun sens
donc à partir du moment où les
américains ne connaissent pas ce
tribunal
pourquoi voulez vous qu'ils seraient le
reconnaissent et beaucoup d'autres pays
ne reconnaissent pas la validité de la
validité de ce tribunal
donc pour l'instant israël ne veut pas
tenir compte de ce qui est dit et je
préfère les décisions internationales de
l'onu des comptes du conseil de sécurité
ou des pays
ceci dit ceci étant dit si nous allons
commencer à parler de juridique bien
nous n'allons nous allons nous enfoncer
dans des débats qui seront foireux il
faut parler de choses concrètes
vous avez dit vous avez dit que vous
êtes engagés
moi je suis en juin un journaliste non
engagées c'est à dire que je n'ai pas
que 2 de carte de parti et je
n'appartiens à aucun parti mais j'essaie
d'être réaliste j'essaye d'être réaliste
si nous sans arrêt nous sortons nous
revenons à des aléas des préceptes
juridiques qui sont contestés par les
uns et par les autres
nous n'avançons pas aujourd'hui il faut
avancer
il y à une situation grave là je viens
encore d'avoir une deuxième à l'est une
deuxième but de 4e à l'air donc c'est
quand même une situation
moi ce que je trouve en dehors de tout
contexte de tout contexte juridique
moi je trouve que envoyé des
missiles sur des populations civiles est
un crime
et là je le vis moi même je le vis moi
même ce que c'est que de recevoir des
missiles alors que nous sommes
je pense nous je parle comme nous
c'étaient les habitants de ce quartier
qui vont recevoir des bombes
nous sommes innocents donc comment
peut-on accepter qu'un la même chose
dans l'autre sens vous le savez jacques
benillouche et c'est tout le voilà le ou
côté explosif de geste confiait denis à
plaire plus de morts du côté palestinien
ça c'est un fait donc c'est vrai mais
dire qu'on va commencer à dire qui a
commencé alors je suis d'accord avec
vous qui a eu des provocations de la
part de la droite israélienne
jeudi elle à l'extrême droite
israélienne qui a voulu en pleine
période de ramadan s'installer en plein
centre de la ville pour essayer de
montrer sa présence est contestée
effectivement la situation de certains
cas mais le problème c'est que il
s'agissait à ce moment-là de
contestation je dirais humaine et non
pas militaire
il est la réponse à cette contestation a
été l'envoyé de l'envoi de missiles je
maintiens que cette ce problème là est
parti d'un problème qui n'était pas
militaire
et nous serons nous nous retrouvons avec
des missiles qui nous tombe sur la tête
ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on va régler le
problème alors que gilles devers
pardonnez moi ce qui fait distribuer la
parole gilles devers quand on entend
jacques benillouche nous dire voilà ce
sont des gens d'extrême droite c'est
vrai que c'est ce qu'on entend souvent
chez des israéliens qui n'ont pas envie
de cette escalade de violence et qui là
déplore ce sont des extrémistes se vend
des deux côtés qui font un petit peu le
le voilà qui met le feu aux poudres dans
ce conflit clairement c'est votre
opinion aussi on a clairement vu qu'il y
avait des manifestations provocatrice
est une chose mais le fond du débat va
au delà c'est à dire c'est la question
de jérusalem est et tout le projet c est
ce que jérusalem est
capital unique de l'état d'israël où est
ce que jérusalem fait partie du
territoire palestinien alors on dit faut
pas d'arguties juridiques mais je veux
bien qu'il ait pas d'abus si je dis
alors de quoi on parle moi je dis si
vous voulez la paix c'est comme cela il
va falloir accepter la cisjordanie
palestinienne la gaza parle de signes n
est gérée à belém palestiniens et c'est
la cpi qu'il dit israël reconnaît pas la
cpi mais mes sessions droite se mettre
en dehors du droit international mais
déjà faudra pas fallait faire des leçons
de droit international quand on leur
jette c'est une première chose
et la deuxième chose c'est que sur
jérusalem est
vous avez des résolutions du conseil de
sécurité le conseil de sécurité dire on
ne reconnaît pas le changement de
constitution qui est nul et non effet et
on ne reconnaît pas l'unification du
jérusalem jérusalem et reste du
territoire palestinien donc tout ça
c'est ce sont des questions indique
indissoluble donc il ya une part pour
l'oeuvre provocation qui est certaine
mais les juges qui s'occupe du
territoire peu palestiniens n'ont aucune
compétence et je vous dis que nous
allons être amenés parce que nous
n'avons pas d'autre solution vu
l'acharnement de ses juges a déposé
plainte contre eux vigueur il se met
complice de la colonisation donc
respecter les frontières la charte de
l'onu lance un article 7 et 10 la
garantie de la paix dans le monde c'est
le respect des frontières dans guérilla
une frontière dans jérusalem
il va falloir sortir les israéliens de
jérusalem-est et rendre à jérusalem est
complètement palestiniens c'est 1,6 ya
des juifs qui elle venir c'est autre
chose
de la même manière si des musulmans veut
s'installer en israël où des chrétiens
sais c'est pas un problème de religion
c'est un problème de statut voilà et il
se trouve que à ce qu'on voit très très
bien au niveau d'un côté certainement
des groupes organisés mais regardez du
côté palestinien je suis proche de tous
les groupes politiques que tous tous
voila j'ai des contacts avec tout ça
c'est mon métier d'être en contact avec
tous d'être un petit peu un avocat
diplomate mai
à jérusalem c'est ni le hamas ni encore
moins le fatah abbas n'a aucune autorité
sur jérusalem et le fatah non plus c'est
une jeunesse qu'est ce qu'elle dit cette
jeunesse et le dire on vit ici on veut
vivre là c'est tout et ça c'est pas une
question d'extrémisme et je me suis le
dire ce n'est pas une question d' alerte
à la bombe
donc respectons israël comme compétence
comme capitale palestinienne
jacques benillouche pardonnez moi avant
de vous laisser répondre je voudrais
inclure un petit peu ces réactions
internationales qu'on sent parfois gênés
d'ailleurs par le silence assourdissant
de joe biden pour le moment l'union
européenne par la voix de joseph bourrel
nous nous dit voilà il faut condamner
les déclarations d'un côté par marc aux
provocations d'un côté mais aussi de
l'autre ça veut dire que la communauté
internationale a par moscou qui nous dit
quand même qu'il y à du droit qu'il faut
le respecter ne semble pas être dans un
camp ni dans l'autre semble un petit peu
embarrassé dans cette affaire pour ne
froisser personne
je pense que si on se place
essentiellement je comprends la
spécialité de mon interlocuteur sur se
place uniquement sur le droit on va pas
avancer parce que les problèmes que nous
avons à leur et pied sont des problèmes
politiques
vous savez que les manifestations durent
hamas ont été lancées par le ramasse
parce qu'il voulait impliquer israël
dans la décision de mahmoud abbas de
reporter les élections
les mahmoud abbas à reporter les
élections
donc il fallait pousser le israël à
intervenir pour permettre que ces
élections aient lieu
sssa l'origine de la ddt du problème on
n'a pas parlé de jérusalem lors de ces
manifestations
les gens qui sont intervenus non pas
parler ils ont demandé des droits de
pouvoir faire les élections comme elles
ont été prévues seulement mahmoud abbas
sait qui va les perdre parce qu'il est
en fin de fin de course
il sait qui va les pertes il a une très
forte il a une très forte opposition au
sein même du fatah et c'est à ce moment
là que l'on veut impliquer israël dans
un conflit entre fatah
le ramage je voudrais vous signaler que
et sanem plus jamais intervenu à gaza il
a quitté gaza en 2005 droit et il
n'intervient plus jamais à gaza il
intervient il n'intervient pas à gaza il
n'y a pas de troupes qui occupent gaza
il n'y a pas il ya des frontières
qu'elle et qui sont respectés
d'un côté comme de l'autre vous avez de
la frontière avec keren shalom au tous
les jours 600 camions traversent la
frontière pour apporter de
l'alimentation élevés de v et des
matériaux à gaza mais mis à part cela il
n'y a pas de contestation qui s'exprime
donc si vous voulez uniquement vous
basez sur le côté juridique on en a des
années à discuter et c'est parce que
monsieur est avocat au barreau de lyon
et est spécialiste en droit
international et de la cause
palestinienne
euh je comprends qu'ils s'appuient sur
des choses qui ne sont pas par exemple
vous avez parlé de jérusalem jérusalem a
été reconnue par les etats-unis et par
quatre autres pays occidentaux
jérusalem est est donc alors et alors ok
alors ça veut dire quand même une
méprise unique de droit il ya eu son de
cloche il ya le son de cloche de
certaines en pétrole dans son gloss et
la facim de verre le mot de la fin s'il
vous plaît la réponse à jacques
benillouche c'est ce qu'on arrive déjà
au terme de ce débat il ya le droit et
les arguties juridiques donc réussi
juridique je pense que je suis pas là
dedans mais les palestiniens et demande
un état est un état ça passe par le
droit pour là c'est comme cela et là
c'est pas des états unis qui font le
droit des états unis viole le droit
depuis hiroshima donc c'est irien nov
voilà maintenant elle veut dire que
c'est le hamas qui manipulent jérusalem
alors j'allais presque dire
il aimerait bien mais l'implantation du
hamas à jérusalem est extrêmement faible
il ya simplement des gens qui glissent
prometteuse rousseau est donc en droit
second niveau et vu qu'on a un égo on
doit participer à la vie
égalité de droits entre un palestinien
israël et bien ça aussi c'est du droit
l'égalité de toutes personnes donc le
peuple continue à demander à vivre en
prêt dans ses frontières
ils se trouvent et qu'une zone de clips
et juridiquement s'est dit par tout le
monde y compris par le conseil de
sécurité fias des réguliers je suis
étonné que vous avanciez des arguties
aussi glossy forces internationales
insolite internationale qui virait de
gaza et les préoccupent et après la
casse et des conventions genève
alors quand plusieurs blocus y a pas un
seul soldat israélien à gaza et gaza le
blocus parler les bateaux les la
surveillance permanente les raids
permanent le nombre de morts qu'il a il
ya les opérations d un blocus et c'est
d'ailleurs vous traitez israël la
question casar soir le ministère des
affaires étrangères et par l'armée avec
une délégation militaire et si vous
laissez passer des camions c'est parce
que vous avez l'obligation en fonction
de la convention de genève
vu que c'est un territoire occupé gaza
est un territoire occupé
merci vous êtes retiré des colonies vous
vous êtes retiré vos soit en conscience
tranquille mais elle donc ça c'est exact
mais tu en avais ce format que
juridiquement il serait de gaza est
occupé et non seulement occupé sous
blocus militaire vous violez vos
découvertes mettent l'egypte et on ne
peut pas dire qu'il y à un blocus alors
parlé avec l'egypte et demande qu'elle
ne mettra pas d'accord ce soir ça fait
des dizaines d'années que ça dure en
tout cas merci d'avoir accepté ce
face-à-face messieurs gilles devers et
jacques benillouche merci à vous deux
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de la fusillade dans une
école de
kazan russie qui a fait au moins neuf
morts et puis direction le royaume uni
avec le traditionnel discours du trône
pour présenter programme législatif
pasco vide de boris johnson
[Musique]
ce sont les trafiquants de drogue
d'une certaine façon qui sont peut-être
les meilleurs adeptes de la
mondialisation c'est à dire que ils ont
inventé les routes de la drogue bien
avant que les entreprises ne découvrent
les bienfaits de la mondialisation on ne
visualise pas à quel point ça peut être
compliqué de se retrouver avec dans son
garage une montagne de billets de banque
comme ça il faut en faire quelque chose
de l'argent sale devient très rapidement
et très facilement en gris et puis blanc
il suffit de passer par quelques
sociétés écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dix nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
à 20h30 soit les bienvenus en direct
huerre tesfran si vous nous rejoignez
fusillade meurtrière ce matin à 15 en
russie bilan provisoire au moins neuf
morts confirmés et une trentaine de
blessés
un adolescent âgé de 19 ans était
interpellé une vingtaine d'ambulances
ont été dépêchés sur place les élèves
eux ont été évacués on prend tout de
suite la direction de moscou pour
rejoindre notre correspondant antoine
claireaux un bon soir antoine pour vous
nous raconter plus en détail ce qui
c'est sur ce qui s'est passé donc
déroulée à 15 ans aujourd'hui
oui bien vers 9h30 un homme armé a fait
irruption dans l'école numéro 175,2
kazan et commence à faire feu
indifféremment sur les élèves et les
professeurs faisant donc un nombre
important de victimes unis puis une
explosion retentit également et grâce au
sang froid des enseignants et à
l'intervention des forces de l'ordre
l'école a pu être évacuée et le forcené
interpellé je vous propose d'écouter
quelques témoignages il y a eu des coups
de feu mon fils dit qu'il y avait eu une
explosion
on a tiré à trois reprises puis il y a
eu une explosion et ensuite le silence
pendant ce temps de silence d'autres
enseignants souvenu pour les évacuer par
la porte de côté
tout d'abord nous avons fermé les salles
de classe les fenêtres nous avons
interdit aux enfants de s'approcher des
fenêtres frais dit coquelin
ça va venir prêcher luxair on leur a dit
de s'accroupir le long du mur et on est
calme et non pas par les secours nous
avons récemment eu l'occasion de
discuter avec d'autres enseignants qui
ont expliqué comment il avait fait pour
sauver les enfants
la première chose qu'ils ont dit a été
de s'éloigner de la fenêtre de nombreux
enfants terrifiés ont sauté des premier
et deuxième étages résultat au moins
neuf morts et parmi eux sept enfants il
ya également une trentaine une trentaine
de blessés parmi eux des enfants âgés
entre 7 et 15 ans un bilan qui
malheureusement est amenée à évoluer
encore étant donné l'état grave de
certains des blessés le principal
suspect que quant à lui le suspect de
cette tuerie est un jeune homme de 19
ans à peine plus âgé que certaines de
ses victimes d'ailleurs on vient de
l'apprendre
le suspect principal est un ancien élève
de cet établissement et vladimir poutine
antoine a décidé de revoir les règles
sur le port d'armes
oui on le fait car le principal suspect
donc de 19 ans seulement venu il ya tout
juste quelques semaines d'obtenir son
port d'armé il avait donc passé avec
succès tous les tests y compris les
tests psychologiques et c'est peut être
bien là le problème certains proposent
donc de changer cette loi de par exemple
repousser l'âge minimum du permis de
port d'armes de 18 à 21 ans la
législation donc concernant ce port dame
doit évoluer c'est en tout cas le
souhait de vladimir poutine écouter
dimitri peskov
le président a chargé le gouvernement
d'apporter son aide d'assurer la
prestation de soins médicaux ainsi qu'un
soutien psychologique aux enfants
touchés et blessés et de fournir une
assistance nécessaire aux familles des
victimes
victor zolotow le directeur de la garde
nationale de russie a été chargée de la
mission spéciale de rédiger d'urgence un
nouveau règlement sur les types d'armes
qui peuvent être vendus au civil est
détenu par la population en prenant en
compte le type d'armes légères utilisées
par la cia le président transmet ses
profondes condoléances aux familles des
enfants tuées par le tireur et adresse
ses voeux de prompt rétablissement aux
écoliers blessés
en attendant la ville de kazan est sous
le choc et de très nombreuses questions
restent sans réponse at il agi seul
avait-il des complices pourquoi avoir
pris pour cible des enfants
autant de questions auxquelles l'enquêté
devra désormais répondre merci antoine
au clairon en direct de moscou et pour
en parler nous sommes avec hadjadj
samueli chercheur au global policy
institute bonsoir de georges samueli
merci d'être avec nous c'est un drame
plutôt rare en russie
n'est ce pas comment peut-on expliquer
et dans quel contexte intervient-il ces
tragédies qui arrive aux états unis et
dans le reste du monde
c'est un individu très troublée qui
souffrent de toute évidence de problèmes
mentaux graves subi hier sa rage sa
frustration
c'est un très bel hématome à des
innocents autour de lui c'est terrible
je me lève
malheureusement ce genre de choses est
arrivé dans le passé continuera sont
toutes arrivées dans le reste du monde
également
alors le suspect à antoine clermont me
disait
avait un permis de port d'armes vous
admire poutine veut donc revoir les
règles régissant le port d'armes en
russie qu'en est il contrairement aux
états unis n'a pas tous ses amendements
qui garantissent une droite port d'armes
donc ils n'ont pas vraiment de culture
de telles armes à feu doux et détention
d'armes à feu par individu également été
reçu quant aux états unis en suisse
donc ce n'est pas un problème en russie
vont sans doute et cultiver une série de
façon de restreindre personnes
l'autorisation de posséder tragédie
montrait peu de lien avec la possession
d'armes à feu lui arrive toutes les
quelques années bien plus souvient
d'ailleurs aux états unis ainsi nous
n'avons pas eu de problèmes similaires
depuis l'on veut résoudre le problème de
la possession des armes a fait une
occasion ne s'y prête pas car c'est un
événement extrêmement rare extrêmement
inhabituelle ce n'est pas le moment de
lancer de grandes réformes sur les
amériques
car c'est un événement extrêmement
inhabituelle clic effectivement un
tragique mais c'est très loin d'être un
exemple typique de violence par les
armes à feu vous avez parlé de la
constitution américaine qui garantit
cela est ce que le lobbying est
similaire qu aux etats unis
concernant justement le port d'armes on
connaît la célèbre nra qui fait du
lobbying pour justement on garantir ce
port d'armes à la population et qui
empêche toute réforme est ce que c'est
la même chose en russie
non je n'y pense pas je ne pense
vraiment pas qu'il y ait tant russie
cession légale est à l'affût se retrouve
presque 21 de la population
ils étaient 350 plus tard mois dans la
population donc hors moyenne c'était une
arme à feu par personne
c'est là c'est parti de la culture
américaine tout cela on égalise possède
des armes pour toute une série très bien
sûr les propriétaires de petites
entreprises les personnes qui ont
beaucoup de liquide chez eux des
fermiers des armes à feu les gens qui
vivent dans de petites communautés
isolées en possède également
donc il ya une série de raisons
légitimes peuvent posséder des armes à
feu ça cependant celle des états unis ou
en russie ce n'est pas du tout le même
sentiment qu'ils étaient arrivés aux
états unis était admiratif face à tous
et le fusil et vous importez cette
culture de fermat feux en russie et
personne ne l'a adopté la russie ne
s'intéressent pas à ce genre de choses
la culture les arts martiaux la culture
si le président bosse je propose des
restrictions sur la possession d'armes à
feu
je ne pense pas qu'il y aura beaucoup de
protestations contrairement aux états
unis bien sûr si
il y aura beaucoup de résistance face à
toute tentative de réformer le droit de
porter des armes à feu merci beaucoup
giorgio samueli d'avoir été avec nous à
voir porter votre analyse sur ce drame
donc cette fusillade qui s'est produit
aujourd'hui à kazan en russie italie
rattrapé par le flux de migrants alors
que 2000 migrants sont arrivés sur les
côtes de lampedusa ces derniers jours le
pays a été sommé de réagir les
explications avec valentin carpentier
les jours se suivent et se ressemblent à
lampedusa l'île italienne doit accoster
des embarcations de fortune avec à leur
bord des migrants venus principalement
de libye ils sont plus de 2000 à être
arrivés dans les dernières 24 heures
un flux journalier encore jamais vues
sur l'île qui inquiète les élus locaux
6000 migrants débarquant en jour la
machine d'accueil tient à peu près le
coût mais si 3000 à 4000 personnes
arrivent
que faisons nous des chiffres qui ne
cessent d'augmenter en 2021 selon le
ministère de l'intérieur près de 13000
personnes ont débarqué sur les côtes
italiennes depuis le début de l'année
contre 4200 en 2020 l'italie a donc été
sommé de réagir au plus vite
le premier ministre mario draghi déjà
confronté à la campagne de vaccination
doit faire face à une nouvelle
problématique
une aubaine pour ses opposants
politiques qui n'ont pas tardé à
s'emparer du sujet avec les millions
d'italiens en difficulté nous ne pouvons
pas nous permettre de nous occuper de
milliers de clandestins
nous lui demandons que l'italie se
comporte comme l'espagne la grèce et la
france qui n'attendent pas l'europe mais
défendre leur territoire par eux mêmes
l'italie doit maintenant compter sur une
aide extérieure les accords de malte de
censé permettre la redistribution
automatique des demandeurs d'asile sont
toujours interrompues à cause de la
crise sanitaire rome compte désormais
sur le prochain conseil européen qui
aura lieu à la fin du mois de mai pour
les réactiver et pour en parler nous
sommes avec neuf simona va
éditorialistes
della serra bonsoir massimo nava merci
d'être avec nous vaccination plan de
relance mario draghi qui se voient
confrontés donc désormais une autre
crise avec cet afflux soudain de
migrants dans une italie déjà bien
souffrante
c'est en un cocktail qui peut s'avérer
explosif du tout parce que la majorité
qui supportent mario draghi est sain ces
moments cette refonte a plus on peut pas
comparer l'émergence dé la pandémie avec
cette mante de crise de débarquement
d'abord parce que c'est vrai qu'ils sont
plus des 2000 qui sont arrivés dans les
dernières deux jours mais qui sont
beaucoup plus que l'année dernière mais
sont très très beaucoup moins
dès les années précédentes donc il faut
pas paniquer avec l'image et avec
surtout la propagande de monsieur savini
lestrem droite pas ce qu'est un chiffre
absolu l'italie a beaucoup moins d
entrée des demandes d'asile et des
réfugiés qu'est la grèce qu'elle allait
mannequin et même la moitié je pense le
plus ou moins de l'espagne et de la
france donc encore pas exagérer c'est
vrai que au niveau politique sa provoc
kb des réactions des polémiques et
naturellement les présidents de conseil
doit réagir
n'est on peut pas un billy
qu'aujourd'hui mais ce savine et c'est
dans la majorité il sue par les
gouvernements donc il fait un peu un
double jeu des propaganda comme il avait
fait monsieur robert hâle hongrie
accusant madame r d d d accueillir d
d'avoir accueilli plus d un million d
vie grande mais tout le monde sait guère
l'allemagne pouvait pas fermer les
portes et donc était impossible
d'arrêter la route balkanique
donc par rapport à ce qui passe dans des
barriques alain gresset seule ville à
côté dé la des lattes de la toule titre
pour le moment c'est pas c'est pas si
grave comme
semble bien évidemment la d12 à cet
appétit déjà submergé des migrantes et
donc c'est un peu la primaire ligne qui
souffre plus des autres pas d autre part
de l'italie mais la distribution à
l'intérieur de l'italie s'y est fait
avec l'organisation en ce sens de
solidarité et selon lé aussi depuis une
sécurité d'intégration n'est et ds ça va
pas si ça la passion des complots comme
comme les cendres et en deuxième
question c'est très importante a noté
que dans les dernières semaines il ya eu
un moment procéder soi disant des
pacification de stabilité qu'a commencé
à marcher en libye avec heures si la
diplomatique les bons potes diplomate
fait par l'italie par la france et avec
les gouvernements officiel d'aujourd'hui
et il ya des traficant avec une aile des
bandes qu'elles sont rentrés dans
l'action passe t il décider des affaires
criminelles sous leur sujet et a
déstabilisé atteignait soudain c'est
enlève la stabilité de la libye crie ça
c'est un problème très important parce
qu'ils sont des pratiquants très connu
et kim déjà identifié et qui sont
maintenant dame dans son très grise
entre la légalité et l'illégalité par
rapport à l'italie mais avec des
protections à l'intérieur de la libye
et ça c est bien évidemment à notre
grande question c'est bien l'écheveau
voter sur la libye oui pardonnez moi de
vous couper j'espère que ça vous devez
pouvoir est bien sûr sous la libye mais
à ce moment il ya enfin tu es bien des
accords qui sont pas respectées en plus
et eni sur l'europe enfin là je sais tu
as et avoir en temps de l'analyse mais
c'est vrai que
l'italie s'est souvent senti seul en
cette dernière année sur ce dossier des
migrants est ce que les choses
s'améliorent sur ce plan mais les
problèmes c'est donc côté d'avoir un
solidarité et européennes est un vrai
politique d'immigration à l'intérieur
des tous les pays européens notamment
les cobayes comme la france l'italie et
l'allemagne
mais au même temps on peut pas
sous-estimer les faits qu est la
proportion des immigrés et des réfugiés
qui arrivent sous la souris en italie
sont beaucoup moins d'essais qui par
exemple sont arrivés à l'allemagne est
aussi et aussi en france donc il faut on
peut pas disproportionnée la
problématique au nom de la solidarité
européenne moi je suis plutôt critique
pour ça même séance à l'italie à travers
ce moment très difficile sur le plan
économique bien évidemment pas ce qu'est
la pandémie a frappé beaucoup et
compliqué beaucoup les choses mais c'est
pas les seuls pays en europe qui est
souffle de la pandémie
aujourd'hui clairement provient qu'on
comprenne d'un point de vue de la france
très très simplement camp des migrants
arrivent sur le sol italien
comme à lampedusa comment sont ils
traités que se passe-t-il pour
concrètement
mais quand que non il ya des centres
d'accueil plus jeunes ils le sont déjà
accueilli pour la dernière nuit dans
sept centres
il ya des hotspots pour les migrations
ou son registre et ils sont accueillis
mais naturellement
s'ils arrivent tout d'un coup dans les
mêmes dans le même endroit ça complique
les choses mais on n'est pas dans la
situation de calais par exemple euros
od l'île grecque de lesbos lesbos on
n'est pas là en ce moment donc il y a
quand même des structures d'accueil et
d'organisation qui qui qui qui s est
démené
déménager les choses et naturellement je
répète c'est très difficile si harry
tout d'un coup dans la nuit mais à ce
problème notre problème aujourd'hui
c'est que normalement c'est la saison où
la mer est très calme et mais c'est ça
qui fait si que les débarquements et
paris commence et à ce moment il ya eu
aussi en coïncidence un peu particulier
c'est à dire que en ce moment il n'y
avait pas eu une na'vi nick italienne ni
libyenne d'aller dans les eaux
territoriales qui pouvait faire
d'intervention dans la mer et donc la
vague est arrivée tout d'un coup tout ça
aussi merci beaucoup au maximum avant de
nous avoir apporté votre analyse un
éditorialiste au corriere della serra
remercier vous en grande-bretagne
première apparition publique d'elizabeth
ii depuis les funérailles du prince
philippe traditionnel discours du trône
cet après midi de la reine d'angleterre
qui s'est rendu à londres accompagné de
son fils le prince charles
un discours sans sa couronne impériale
pour présenter le programme législatif
poste kovy du premier ministre boris
johnson
l'heure est désormais à l'allègement des
restrictions sanitaires
outre-manche la priorité de mon
gouvernement sera d'assurer un
redressement national
après la pandémie pour rendre le royaume
uni plus fort plus sain et plus prospère
qu'avant pour y parvenir mon
gouvernement renforcera les opportunités
à travers tout le royaume uni
en soutenant l'emploi les entreprises et
la croissance économique et en
s'attaquant à l'impact de la pandémie
sur les services publics une législation
sera introduite pour contrecarrer les
activités hostiles des états étrangers
mais ministre mettront en oeuvre la
revue intégré de la sécurité de la
défense du développement et de la
politique étrangère et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct depuis leicester
avec alister jones professeur associé de
politique à l'université de montfort 2
hester c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir à leicester
jones perd 6 d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france boris johnson qui ressort
donc vainqueurs de ces élections avec un
sièges supplémentaires à la chambre des
communes le parti conservateur qui était
encore en difficulté 1 il ya peu
pourrait être le parti de demain le
parti de l'avenir
[Musique]
le parti conservateur effectivement
réussi à tirer beaucoup de soutien et
cette élection partielle montre que
brigitte est toujours très important
pour les britanniques avec la
vaccination bien sûr donc n'accompagne
vaccination marche très bien et bronson
endosser toute la responsabilité de ces
victoires villa il a donc beaucoup de
bonne volonté dans le pays envers lui et
il espère que cela va continuer
c'est plein tel qu'indiqué dans le
discours de la reine le discours du
trône montre qu'il a beaucoup d'idées
mais qui ne coûte pas grand chose pour
le moment
alors quand ton parti travailliste un
mot sur lui quand même avec son ancien
leader du j'avais mes copines tenu
responsable de la déroute électorale des
législatives de décembre 2019
aujourd'hui c'est écrire star mais qui
espère faire remonter le parti pourquoi
cela n'a pas fonctionné
le problème pour les parties travaillent
et se saisit d'une part également la
vaccination
le parti travailliste a du mal à lutter
contre le parti conservateur car il est
très difficile de lutter contre la
campagne de vaccination le parti
travailler cependant a beaucoup gagné
mais on n'aura pas beaucoup parler dans
la presse de mr pas
simple dans des régions de toute
l'angleterre tt ont été gagnés ou
maintenir par le parti travailliste mais
il ya eu cette réaction générale sur le
fait qu' ils ont perdu plusieurs sièges
il faut savoir que le parti conservateur
a perdu beaucoup de sièges dans le sud
au vert au profil du parti travailliste
les pour le moment le parti travailliste
se concentre sur les mauvais résultats
alors que dans certaines régions du pays
leur stratégie a bien fonctionné
elles ont cependant league il ya eu des
victoires et des défaites oublie souvent
c'est que ces élections c'est des
élections locales
pour des problématiques locales étudie
adopté la même stratégie il étudie
l'impact sur les régions centrales et
oublie tout le niveau local alors entre
dossier les deux parties écossais
favorables à l'indépendance ont renforcé
leur majorité au parlement d'edimbourg
en cette semaine et souhaite désormais
l'organisation d'un nouveau référendum
le premier ministre lui y est opposé un
britannique
quelle peut être l'issue de ce dossier
épineux vient constitue chevaux s
constitution si wes masters refuse à
l'heure c'est l'os et cloud car le
référendum est un pouvoir du
gouvernement tous les référendums
doivent se faire à westminster en
angleterre la santé et les verts
écossais souhaite effectivement un
référendum indépendant il pourrait en
organiser un messi ne s'agirait que d'un
référendum consultatif
s'il voulait un référendum contraignant
alors oui si mister devrait organiser
donc un court terme rien ne va changer
le smp les verts vont exprimer leur
volonté de référendum mais ne pourront
pas en organiser le court terme et c'est
de se préparer sur le référendum est de
sortir de la période qu'ovide si l'on
regarde les résultats entre les
personnes pour et contre le référendum
il ya une division 50 50 en écosse une
moitié de l écosse à voter pour des
partis pro indépendance et d'autres pour
des parties prônions l'ecosse et divisé
donc une la question est quand
faudra-t-il organiser le référendum
je ne pense pas qu'il y ait que la star
jeunes va essayer pour les 18 mois pour
les deux ans à venir aux cours en tout
cas de ce mandat parlementaire assez de
temps pour amasser encore plus de
soutien populaire et avec un peu de
chance elle pourra organiser un
référendum qui sera victorieux mais
effectivement le temps en politique que
ses coûts très vite donc il faut
attendre
merci beaucoup à l'histoire jaws
professeur associé de politique à
l'université de montfort de l'investor
d'avoir été avec nous restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons du
calendrier de déconfinement détaillé ce
soir en france cette fois-ci par le
premier ministre jean castex et puis
nous reviendrons sur le pass sanitaires
à la surprise générale il a été rejeté
par l'assemblée aujourd'hui le
gouvernement a perdu sa majorité à cause
de la défection des députés du modem qui
ont lâché ceux de la majorité
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour à ba et là on
est alors je suis arrivé en 2005 pour
étudier dernière fois celle en profiter
en 2011 le monde manque pas un petit peu
non ah oui et c'est tous les fromages
tous les soucis sont toutes les les
croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui te plaît
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
les français ne savent pas je ne pensais
jamais de ma vie faire de la plongée ans
et demi vous pouvez me souhaiter bon
courage
[Musique]
à très bientôt sur arte france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le ms a exhorté certains pays africains
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti
qu'ovide péri mais il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique non une
vaccination reste une vaccination savez
la vaccination ce n'est pas elle n'a pas
commencé avec la guitare
le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement est ce que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les productions de
l'accent où est le mécanisme de la
vaccination vous savez ça a soulevé
beaucoup d'enjeux sur la question de la
solidarité
si on peut en faire plus en terme de
solidarité de partage de ces bacs celle
là c'est quelque chose d'absolument
importants ainsi que le nigeria affirme
qu'il élabore son propre vaccin contre
le coc vie de 19 pour en finir avec
justement la dépendance vis-à-vis des
laboratoires étrangers que ça soit le
sénégal le nigeria l'afrique du sud
beaucoup de pays en cette ambition
l'avoir amené la générale de la santé
publique au top des priorités c'est
quelque chose que nous saluons
énormément au niveau de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
[Musique]
le théâtre du châtelet c'est pas un
théâtre comme les autres c'est un
théâtre qui est très diversifiée dans sa
programmation de la culture est une
activité absolument essentiel de notre
société de sa cohésion de sa cohérence
c'est aussi le rôle du châtelet de
pouvoir mettre en contact des très
belles productions avec le public
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans un théâtre en
plein confinement on a essayé de
réinventer notre métier et en
particulier on a fait beaucoup de
travail avec la télévision on a permis
de capter un certain nombre de
spectacles pour la télévision ce qui est
une autre manière de pouvoir créer la
relation avec le public je suis sûr
qu'il y aura une grande volonté du
public de revenir dans les théâtres
[Musique]
21h merci de rejoindre pour cette
deuxième des missions tout de suite
voici les types de l'actualité de ce
mardi 11 mai interview de jean castex
tout à l'heure chez nos confrères de
france 2 le déconfinement toujours
d'actualité le 19 mai le premier
ministre qui se veut rassurant raison
d'une évolution épidémique plutôt
favorables et grâce à la vaccination
il y aura bien un pass sanitaire
promet-il avec de nouvelles
délibérations dès ce soir à l'assemblée
alors que les députés l'ont rejeté un
peu plus tôt nous reviendrons sur cette
prise de parole avec alexis poulain dans
notre édito là aiment toujours un voile
jeté sur la campagne aux élections
départementales celui porté par une
candidate remplaçante sur une affiche de
campagne le parti majoritaire se
déchirent sur cette question dans
l'hérault autorisé par la loi gabriela
talent précise tout de même ne pas
souhaiter présenter une candidate avec
un signe ostensible religieux un avis
que ne partage pas plusieurs députés de
la république en marche la sphère luc
slicks jugement aujourd'hui de la cour
européenne en faveur du grand duché la
justice luxembourgeoise n'a pas violé
les dispositions de la convention
européenne sur la liberté d'expression
parce qu'elle a condamné à une amende
l'informateur d'un journaliste dans
cette vaste affaire des visions
d'évasion fiscale
[Musique]
le premier ministre est donc revenu sur
la campagne de vaccination les retards
pris dans l'injection astrazeneca qui
font que l'objectif des 20 millions de
vaccinés ne sera pas forcément tenu le
15 mai comme prévu initialement
le chef du gouvernement qui a surtout
insisté sur la nécessité de se faire
vacciner avec le sérum astrazeneca
écouter les retard que nous avons pris
dans l'injection d'astrazeneca ou les
plus de 55 ans font que la cible de 20
millions de primo vacciner à la mi mai
sera pas loin d'être atteinte
j'en suis pas absolument sûr ce soir il
ya eu dans le chiffre que vous avez
donné 400 milles vaccination primo
vaccination semblent je pense qu'il est
à notre portée de dire que si on en fait
autant jusqu'au 15
on sera pas loin d'arriver très plus que
huit jours donc avant les premières
mesures de déconfinement ce lundi
matignon a rendu publics les détails du
calendrier gouvernemental des
réouvertures en trois étapes
les 19 mai le 9 juin et 30 juin pour la
plupart je vous propose d'en découvrir
les grandes lignes en images
le 19 mai les cafés bars et restaurants
pour ouvrir leur terrasse à 50% de leurs
capacités partout en france pour des
tables et de six convives maximum le 9
juin ce sera au tour des salles en
intérieur à moitié de leurs capacités
notez que la consommation et le service
au bar restaurant interdite enfin le 30
juin sous réserve de la situation
sanitaire
les établissements recevront à 100 % de
leur capacité d'accueil les étudiants
reprennent les cours le 19 mai avec une
jauge de 50% des effectifs
les examens universitaires sont reportés
à partir du 9 juin à l'exception des
concours nationaux examen en santé qui
sont eux maintenus les salles de sport
piscine entre autres rouvre pour tous
les publics à 50% le 9 juin et en
totalité le 30
le sport en intérieur reprend en
revanche dès le 19 mai pour les mineurs
concernant les sports de combat
il faudra attendre le 30 juin prochain
au 19 mai l'accueil redevient possible
dans les établissements vacanciers
proposant des hébergements individuels
ou familiaux les lieux collectifs
d'accueil des mineurs pourront ouvrir le
20 juin
la réouverture des magasins le 19 mai se
fera avec une jauge d'un client pour
huit mètres carrés puis à compter du 9
juin 1 pour 4 mètres carrés
cette jauge doit disparaître le 30 juin
concernant les monuments et musées
le principe est exactement le même une
jauge de 8 mètres carrés dans un premier
temps et fin de la jauge le 30 juin
prochain enfin si les conditions
sanitaires le permettent le couvre-feu
devrait progressivement disparaître
d'ici au 30 juin
d'abord repoussé à 21h à partir du 19
mai puis 23 heures le 9 juin c'est une
surprise l'assemblée nationale a voté ce
mardi contre l'article du projet de loi
de sortie de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
qui prévoyait le retour au pass
sanitaire controversé l'article 1er été
rejetée par 108 voix contre 103
critiquant le manque de dialogue c'est
le modem ou leur ai fait pencher la
balance en lâchant la république en
marche
le gouvernement a d'ores et déjà demandé
une seconde délibération en écoute jean
castex la divergence ne portait pas sur
le pass sanitaire mais sur l'engin date
la date de sortie de l'urgence sanitaire
corps que par prudence par précaution
nous avions fixé à la fin du mois
d'octobre 31 octobre et que un certain
nombre d'élus de la majorité voulait
anticiper ou souhaite dissiper au 30
septembre commence à se trouver un
accord avec la majorité
normal comme majorité des bad c'est vrai
que les mesures qu'ils s'attachent la
gestion de la crise sanitaire sont des
mesures contraignantes pour nos
concitoyens font appel que nous y sommes
depuis le mois de mars 2020 donc c'est
normal qu'il y ait débat
ce problème nous allons le régler je
suis sûr il y aura une nouvelle
délibération dès ce soir il y aura un
pass and italy durant la france approche
donc à grands pas du déconfinement mais
à pas comptés
mesures décidées vont peut-être
permettre de sortir durablement de la
crise pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexis pour lancer notre rubrique
l'édito bonsoir alexis poule a alors le
passé ni terre c'est la vedette de la
soirée at il une chance oui au nom de
passer oui clairement on a vu les
déclarations de jean castex en disant
qu'il y aura une nouvelle délibération
stanislas guérini a dit qu'il y aura un
pass oui il faut absolument qu'il y ait
un pass ce qu'il s'est passé ce soir
c'est simplement le modem qui rappelle à
la majorité présidentielle combien cette
formation politique est importante pour
la cohésion de la majorité
présidentielle pour les régionales
et pour la suite françois bayrou a peur
de disparaître dans la sphère et le
modem fait bien entendre sa voix en dix
ans attend dé nous allons débattre
certes dupas sanitaire mais surtout de
la place de la formation politique modem
dans l'avenir de la candidature
d'emmanuel macron pour 2022 le pass
sanitaires il faudrait qu'il y ait un
débat de bioéthique long réelle au sein
des assemblées
il n'aura pas lieu il va être fait dans
la précipitation avec l'idée bien sûr de
la vaccination et l'idée c'est de faire
une scène steve de pousser les gens à se
vacciner pour avoir ce fameux sésame qui
leur permettra de voyager d'aller un peu
partout on a vu en allemagne comment les
les soudain tout est devenu ouvert pour
les vacciner l'idée c'est de faire la
même chose en france de donner envie en
disant que si vous êtes vacciné vous
pourrez aller où vous voulez grâce à ce
pas ce merveilleux même si aujourd'hui
le pass sanitaire peut exister si vous
avez un pc est négatif ou une immunité
mais il faut encadrer bien sûr la durée
encadrer le périmètre savoir combien de
temps ça va durer est ce que c'est une
mesure qui va durer dans le temps est ce
qu'on est en train d'ouvrir les portes
vers un système de biocontrôle est
dangereux pour nos libertés dangereux
pour la démocratie
ou bien est-ce que c'est simplement
quelque chose pour pousser les français
à aller se faire vacciner pour être
tranquille parce qu'on en a marre
évidemment on veut que ça ouvre mais ça
me paraît être un peu léger comme débat
parlementaire comme débats de bioéthique
de dire simplement
vous faire vacciner prenait 1 passe et
n'en parlons plus derrière il ya quand
même des questions philosophiques morale
beaucoup plus profonde que celle de se
faire vacciner le plus rapidement
possible alors le premier ministre a
évidemment parlé de ce déconfinement que
beaucoup attendent un déconfinement
prudent mais un déconfinement tout de
même oui alors c'est un déconfinement
compliqué on sent quand même qu'il ya
beaucoup de travail un des cabinets de
conseil que ce soit mckeen's est bonne
et les autres alors il ya des dates il
ya des horaires il n'y a pas plus de 6 à
tables des terrasses avec des jauges
j'ai eu du mal à lire et à comprendre
l'ensemble de l'image en gros au 30 juin
ça devrait aller
parce que ce sera l'été et donc on verra
sachant que les masques on les gardera
jusqu'à la fin de l'été a priori mais
bon l'idée c'est de passer un été à peu
près normale avec des gestes barrières
quand même avec des gens vaccinés avec
un fameux pass sanitaires pour les
événements on parle des festivals on
parle des événements au dessus de 1000
personnes
mais par exemple le tour de france si
vous êtes le long de la route pas de
passes sanitaire c'est en plein air tout
va bien est ce qu'un jour on va enfin
pouvoir enlever le masque en extérieur
vu qu'il ne sert pas à grand chose ça ça
n'est pas dans la loi on verra ça reste
beaucoup de questions beaucoup de
questions particulièrement de la part
des commerçants on a vu combien le monde
de la nuit est inquiète les
propriétaires de boîtes de nuit qui
manifestaient qui criaient leur angoisse
et même leur colère leur désarroi
redisant nous sommes les grands oubliés
finalement de 7,2 ce déconfinement les
restaurateurs eux sont pris en compte
les aides aussi aux entreprises vont
être dégressive
mais même avec les aides mises en place
on voit bien que ça va être compliqué
pour les centres commerciaux pour les
commerces on parle de l'ouverture le
dimanche c'est aussi une façon de faire
rentrer par la petite porte l'ouverture
le dimanche
pourtant critiquée par de nombreux
syndicats en france et le manque à
gagner va rester malgré ces mesures de
déconfinement on sait bien qu'une
terrasse même si elle est élargie à 50%
ce n'est pas une terrasse à 6 à table ce
n'est pas une terrasse une salle du
restaurant qui n'ouvre pas avant le 30
juin ce n'est pas une salle de resto
ouverte il ya des frais fixes
il y à du personnel à payer donc ça
reste très compliqué on va dans le bon
sens
évidemment il faut rouvrir on voit que
derrière il ya la volonté d'aller plus
vite de rouvrir de passer à autre chose
même s'ils ont des confine alors qu'on
est quand même à plus de 4000 personnes
en réanimation alors que lors du premier
des confinement en était seulement à
2000 personnes en réanimation donc c'est
vous dire
comme finalement les jauges les chiffres
ont changé on s'adapte après tout il
faut rouvrir coûte que coûte
c'est un peu ça le quoi qu'il en coûte
alors on se souvient mathieu
déconfinement à l'origine devenu premier
ministre at il appris ou bien emmanuel
macron qu'on style un petit peu l'agenda
oui alors c'est vrai que jean castex il
a été en charge du déconfinement avant
de devenir premier ministre
c'était à l'époque edouard philippe le
premier ministre et lui jean castex qui
gérait le déconfinement qui a été
finalement un grand lâcher prise ça a
été le virus est terminée allons-y c'est
l'été rappelez-vous 2020 l'été c'était
normal c'était la fête
emmanuel macron faisait du jet ski on
était tous à la plage avait pas de
masquer les restaurants avaient réouvert
n'y avait pas de masque de toute façon
vous allez me dire il y avait pas de
vaccin non plus là on se rend compte que
en 2021 on a des vaccins on a des
masques on a des gestes des barrières on
a un peu appris on a aussi beaucoup de
gens qui sont réanimation et on se dit
qu'il va falloir être un peu plus
prudent parce qu'on entre en campagne
électorale et clairement ce choix du
calendrier depuis le début c'est madame
lac rond qui décide qui veut rester
maître des horloges contrariée avec ce
virus
le choix de faire le nom confinement en
janvier alors que nos voisins européens
confie d'air en janvier en zone que nous
gagnons des jours précieux de liberté
alors avec un couvre-feu à 19 heures
avec un confinement quand même les
commerces fermés avec plus de 300 morts
par jour on est à plus de 100 106 mille
morts aujourd'hui en france on a appelé
ça gagne et de la liberté c'est beaucoup
de gens qui ont perdu en liberté ils
sont morts et aujourd'hui on se retrouve
avec une situation extrêmement volatile
extrêmement dangereuse si jamais la
vaccination n'arrivais pas à avoir un
effet ou à être suffisante pour contrer
la propagation des variantes qui sont de
toute façon sur le territoire est là que
nous dit jean castex qu'il va falloir
écouler les doses d'astrazeneca que oui
on joue on ne sait pas à paris n'ont
bien entendu on fait un bon choix que
les choix en janvier était aussi des
bons choix c'est à dire que
systématiquement avec cette majorité ils
ne font que des bons choix il n'y a pas
de mea culpa ya pas de retour sur
finalement ce qui n'a pas marché
tout va très bien dans le meilleur des
mondes
et c'est grâce à emmanuel macron le
meilleur des présidents du monde
à un moment on peut quand même se poser
des questions et se dire est ce que là
on n'est pas en train de faire un
nouveau pari et finalement de se payer
un était alors pas normal puisqu'il aura
le pass annie terre les jauges les
gestes barrière simplement attendre que
le prochain confinement arrive en
septembre octobre
ce serait catastrophique parce qu'on va
rentrer dans une campagne présidentielle
je pense qu emmanuel macron en est très
conscient donc si il choisi d'accélérer
le calendrier c'est qu'il pense que le
vaccin aura son effet et qu'il n'y aura
pas de futur confinement quitte à jouer
encore davantage avec les chiffres en
faisant monter les soldes alerte que ce
soit sur le nombre de cas que ce soit
sur le nombre de morts le nombre de gens
en réanimation
on voit bien que les chiffres sont
flexibles puisque ont des consignes on
confine alors que les chiffres ont
empiré depuis qu'on a confiné le mois
dernier alexis enfin il faut mieux
confie néant puisque les commerçants eux
sont très inquiet a notamment les boîtes
de nuit à titre d'exemple les quelques
mesures de compensation cela peut-il
suffire après tous ces mois de vaches
maigres voire de pâques vaches du tout
d'ailleurs
c'était des mois de fermeture tout court
alors c'est ce sur quoi table bruno le
maire le ministre de l'économie
un énorme rebond de la consommation
quand les commerces vont réouvrir que ce
soit les restaurants mais les commerces
plus classique en disant qu'il y aura
une appétence des français à consommer
ça veut dire que la confiance serait
revenue et que on n'aurait pas une crise
sociale qui s'ancre est avec l'entrée
dans la précarité ou dans le chômage de
nombreux français aujourd'hui si on
regarde les indicateurs ils sont plutôt
bons à la fois sur les promesses
d'emplois à la fois sur les chiffres de
croissance le pib a été descendu
tellement bas qu'il ne peut que remonter
aujourd'hui même s'il est encore très
bas par rapport à ses niveaux d'avant
2020 donc à bercy l'optimisme est de
mise à la fois pour rassurer les marchés
les commerçants et les français
la réalité c est ce que cet optimisme va
s'ancrer dans les faits est ce que l'été
va être un été qui va permettre aux
commerces de respirer aujourd'hui les
commerces notamment dans les zones
touristiques savent très bien que ce
sera un été différent des autres avec
beaucoup moins de touristes avec des
gestes-barrières avec des protocoles
on ne sera pas du tout dans le cadre de
2020 ou dans les années où il n'y avait
pas de co vite donc le manque à gagner
existera et à bercy on se veut encore
rassurant en disant que les la fin des
aides sera progressive et qu'on arrivera
quand même à gérer les faillites même si
elles seront nombreuses
rappelons le il ya plus de 2 7 à 8
milliard provisionné 1 de non
remboursement du prêt garanti par l'état
pour les faillites des entreprises plus
le nombre d'entreprises aujourd'hui en
procédure de redressement et elles sont
nombreuses et les entreprises qui ont
déjà mis la clé sous la porte il suffit
d'aller dans
dans quelques villes et villages
français de voir que les pas de portes
aujourd'hui à vendre ou à louer et
certains entrepreneurs ont complètement
arrêté leur business vous préfère ne pas
recommencer dans des conditions
dégradées donc il
il faudra attendre et voir quelles
seront les chiffres du 2ème et 3ème
trimestre en france après l'été pour
savoir si le pari du rebond de bruno le
maire a fonctionné et si les aides
pourront sauver la majorité des
entreprises françaises
aujourd'hui sachant que les indicateurs
restent plutôt positif du côté de bercy
merci vocaux alexis poulain pour cette
analyse complète et les soignants les
soignants des services de réanimation et
des unités de soins critiques mobilisés
ce mardi à marseille objectif obtenir
une meilleure reconnaissance de leur
exercice et des valorisations salariales
ont fait le point avec mes yves à saraf
venue de marseille et de ses alentours
ils sont plusieurs centaines à défiler
dans les rues de la capitale phocéenne
ce mardi matin les professionnels des
services de réanimation infirmiers aides
soignants réclame une formation
spécifique diplômante en règle générale
nous en tout cas au ch de toulon on a la
chance d'être d'être doublé huit
semaines pour les infirmiers et deux
semaines prend les aides soignants mais
au-delà de ça pour acquérir les
compétences suffisantes et pour se
sentir à l'aise au sein de son travail
et en toute sécurité
il faut un an actuellement aucune
formation n'est dispensé dans leur école
tous apprennent le métier sur le tas en
doublon avec d'autres praticiens plus
expérimentés je peux pas dire grâce
parce que c'est pas le mot mais
à cause de cette crise qu on a vraiment
mis le doigt sur sur la spécificité
parce que il a fallu augmenter le nombre
de lits rapidement en un temps record et
du coup augmenter le personnel donc
d'aidés soignants pour la plupart
volontaires sont venus nous prêter main
forte
mais ces gens là étaient pas du tout
capable de prendre en charge des malades
de réanimation un défaillance
multiviscérale donc c'est là où on s'est
rendu compte qu'effectivement c'était
compliqué et c'est l'arrêt à ça
s'invente pas ces professionnels
demandent également des moyens délits du
personnel mais aussi une revalorisation
salariale
alors moi je parle pour moi ça fait dix
ans que je suis infirmière en
réanimation
avant la crise du coc vide j'étais à
1880 euros
nex aujourd'hui j'ai tellement fait j'ai
doublé mon temps de travail avec les
heures supplémentaires avec tout ça donc
mon salaire est pas représentatif de ce
que je dois gagner de base parce que
mais j'ai travaillé j'ai plus gagné
effectivement parce que j'ai fait des
énormément d'heures supplémentaires mais
ce qui veut dire moins de repos et voilà
c'est vêtus de leurs blouses de travail
qu'ils ont défilé dans les rues de
marseille pancartes à la main
épuisé après une année face au coc u19
mais loin d'être abattu
enfin des blocus dans plusieurs lycées
nombreux blocages ce matin illustration
à paris sur ces images des étudiants
dénoncent les conditions de travail dans
lesquelles ils sont plongés depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire
parmi les demandes des élèves le passage
un bac en contrôle continu aussi des
mesures sanitaires renforcés dans les
classes pour en parler nous sommes avec
mathieu de vlaeminck à président de
l'union nationale
bonsoir monsieur de vlaeminck merci
d'être avec nous des blocages donc on
vient de le dire partout en france
malgré les annonces de jean michel
blanquer d'aménager l'épreuve de
philosophie
vos revendications persiste pour quelles
raisons oui devant une question persiste
parce que les lycéens ne sont pas du
tout du jeu de communication de gentioux
bancaire qui essaient plutôt que de
penser au bien être des lycéens et de
prendre une solution distribution de
pragmatisme à isoler de mettre en place
le contrôle continu
parce que les lycéens ne sont pas prêts
à passer leurs épreuves cette année au
plus des circonstances dans lesquelles
on a eu recours à une primaire en fait
c'est de sauver son bilan éducatif qui
me jean-michel blanquer revendiquer
d'une copie qui est très mauvaise cette
année parce qu'on a des lycées qui sont
de véritables le cluster parce qu'on a
eu des suppressions professeurs qui ont
entraîné en fait des difficultés pour
les élèves on a un décrochage scolaire
donc il ya une colère qui est réparé
chimio distincts qui contient de
s'exprimer malgré ces annonces qui n'ont
été que de la poudre aux yeux finalement
alors le grand oral c'est là la grande
nouveauté de cette année comment les
élèves l'appréhendent ou santé
suffisamment préparés non ce sont pas
prêts et la raison assez simple c'est
que l'on ne sait pas en quoi consiste sa
tête on devait avoir deux ans préparé
cette épreuve
le résultat c'est qu'on a deux semaines
n'ont pas préparé en deux semaines une
étape qui devait se préparer en deux ans
de plus à la gynécologue qui paraît
fondamental mans discriminante
parce qu'on va être jugé tsonga passe de
grattoirs soit un traiteur hellickson
entre éloquence et face à l'école n'a
pas su jouer son rôle de réduire les
inégalités sociales qui sont le lit des
voix la capacité de prendre la parole
il y aura quand même mort on l'a entendu
de la bouche du ministre une forme
d'indulgence vous n'avez pas confiance
en vos professeurs ça il y aura
peut-être pas là la sévérité habituelles
concernant ces examens
mais sinon notamment combien de
professeurs et c'est les premières de
soutien dans la mobilisation
par contre on a pas que dans son jean
michel blanc car actuellement qui
refusent d'écouter les lycéens qui
méprise les districts ignore les lycéens
depuis des mois et des mois qui ne fait
aucun pas vers nous stuff des annonces
des mesurettes et star en a marre donc
nous concrètement ce qu'on attend du
ministre c'est de l' écoute on le voit
toujours dans les écoles primaires dans
l'école maternelle pour aller jouer à la
marelle pour garder espoir a été listé
un nom l'a jamais vu selon au blocus
sans nous ce qu'on attend c'est que
jeune lanka écoutent les revendications
des lycéens et des lycéennes et se rend
compte qu'elle est la réalité du milieu
10 1 aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui quelle est cette réalité on
s'approche d'un déconfinement est-ce que
vous vous sentez le moral remonter un
petit peu dans dans vos troupes on sait
que ça a été évidemment à une année
extrêmement compliqué pour vous c'est
déjà compliqué et on a vu que les jeunes
de mer général ont fait preuve d'une
grande résilience
mais ça suffit pas nous on a
l'impression qu'on a mieux qui est très
mobilisé qui est courageux en fait et ça
ne reconnaît pas à ces conditions que le
baccalauréat il est donné que les élèves
sont des fainéants mais on se rend pas
compte qu'être élèves aujourd'hui c'est
étudié dans des créations des 35
on n'a pas en permanence t'appelle
coronavirus où on a une enquête
parlementaire qui révèle qu'un étudiant
sur six est en saison le décrochage
scolaire et c'est la même chose dans les
lycées où on a une précarité qui
s'intensifie parce que nos parents peut
aussi tomber au chômage qui va avoir des
coûts des conséquences sur nos capacités
d'études donc on vit une époque qui est
très compliqué est passé à laquelle
l'état ne joue pas son rôle
donc on se sent totalement délaissé
totalement abandonnée et on nous on
salue le fait qu'il ya un an de
solidarité qui se crée pas ça
aujourd'hui avec cette 6e coronavirus
doit-on s'inquiéter de la chute du
nombre des lèvres en école supérieure
je pense qu'il faut qu'on s'y attende il
ya deux phénomènes en fait on va avoir
un nombre important d'élèves qui vont
arriver à l'unss d'enseignement
supérieur qui vous candidatez
l'enseignement supérieur parce que on a
de plus en plus d'élèves dans les lycées
et de surcroît on va avoir des personnes
en licence 1 qui ont massivement
redoublé parce qu'on a deux complexes
d'échec scolaire aussi à la pac
donc pour l'instant on n'a aucun plan
pour nous expliquer comment on va gérer
cet afflux d'élèves qui va venir à la
fin du fait que beaucoup d'élèves en l1
ont redoublé et que beaucoup d'élèves de
terminale vont vouloir à laraque est la
seule solution à mon avis tu es par le
gouvernement ça va être de refuser
massivement à l'entrée des néo
bacheliers et ça c'est scandaleux parce
que l'éducation
ça devrait atteindre
inaliénable un bien immense batteur que
tout le monde devrait pas posséder et
actuellement ce n'est plus le cas merci
messieurs de vlaeminck d'avoir été avec
nous à voir donc témoigner de la
situation et du mécontentement des
lycéens aujourd'hui cérémonie d'hommage
cet après-midi avignon un recueillement
présidée par jean castex en mémoire des
rythmes et sons policiers tués mercredi
dernier le tireur présumé formellement
identifié par le second policier présent
le soir du drame ainsi que son complice
sont présentés aujourd'hui à des juges
il nie les faits on écoute le chef du
gouvernement
rendre un hommage national à l'effet que
massoud honorer sa mémoire
être fidèle à l'élimination
c'est d'abord dire qu'il est hors de
question d'accepter l'inacceptable
une mission qu'elle sa noblesse et ses
dangers aussi mais qui pourtant jamais
ne devrait s'accomplir dans la mort de
l'un des fonds
je devrais dire de l'un des nôtres car
éric masson était avant tout un
fonctionnaire de la nation oui un
fonctionnaire comme sa collègue
stéphanie mon ferme est sauvagement
assassiné à l'entrée du commissariat de
rambouillet et donc j'ai prononcé
l'éloge il ya quelques jours après
c'était des serviteurs de l'état
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons des polémique qui enflait
qui divise le parti majoritaire en cause
le voile porté par une candidate sur une
affiche de campagne des élections
départementales pour ou contre le port
du voile sur les affiches électorales ce
sera l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
non
vous êtes renversé par un homme de 92
ans qui perd le contrôle de son véhicule
deux ans et demi plus tard vous vous
imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris y sommes le sport
m'a toujours sauver le tennis c'est que
c'est mon sport
bon il ya un fauteuil mais je vais
essayer et en fait je me suis rendu
compte que ça allait c'était
suffisamment physique pour moi j'ai une
vie de sportif de haut niveau je
m'entraîne tous les jours c'est devenu
ma vie la raison de me lever le matin
j'avais toujours ce vieux rêve de petite
fille de faire du sport de ma vie est
finalement là c'est ce que je réalise
avec le jambon manger un autre combat on
ma vie qui est celui de la sécurité
routière s'agit d'un projet de loi qui
vise à mettre en place des tests
d'aptitude pour tous les conducteurs pas
seulement les seniors on a un contrôle
technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit doit imposer
loi sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
outre atlantique les états unis semblent
devenir le porte étendard d'une idée qui
n'est pourtant pas nouvelle instaurer un
impôt minimum mondial sur les bénéfices
des entreprises plutôt que de plaider
pour un taux d'imposition minimal
mondiale il faudrait aussi plaidé pour
une fiscalité beaucoup plus transparente
niveau mondial en fait c'est un coup de
com je rappelle que bayonne n'a pas été
élu président du monde
il est trop simpliste de penser qu en
augmente au taux d'imposition va faire
rentrer plus d'argent dans les caisses
c'est beaucoup plus facile de noyer le
poisson en parlant de rimbaud mondial
pour faire passer une hausse des impôts
chez lui vous aurez des augmentations
d'impôts dans tous les pays
les what ever in text le problème c'est
qu'il ya toujours un pigeon à la fin qui
est là pour pays
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire que notre peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sent du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
dignité gilet jaune c'était des valeurs
de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la ligue
parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est on
dirait qu'il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières
la première c'est par la loi et ensuite
progresser parce que nous appelons des
pratiques professionnelles protectrice
la justice à sa part dans cette impunité
comment souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
[Musique]
21h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france la république en marche au centre
des polémiques à la suite d'une affiche
électorale à montpellier en cause la
remplaçant d'un candidat qui porte le
voile sur la photo stanislas guerrini
délégué général du parti a réclamé le
changement de ce cliché sous peine d'une
retraite candidature à la vie que ne
partage pas d'autres députés du parti
présidentiel les explications de david
khalifa sall rasé mailly ne pensais pas
faire autant parler d'elle et pourtant
au sein de la majorité cette candidate
remplaçante aux élections
départementales dans le canton de
montpellier 1 a provoqué un véritable
tollé
avec cette photo un cliché immédiatement
pointé du doigt par l'opposition
notamment le rassemblement national qui
n'a pas manqué d'ironiser c'est cela la
lutte contre le séparatisme marlène
schiappa le voile islamique n'a rien à
faire sur une affiche électorale en
france
la république en marche pratique un
mélange d'idéologie et de clientélisme
très dangereux côté les républicains
aussi on s'indigne éric ciotti parle d'
hypocrisie en marche
valérie boyer sénatrice des bouches du
rhône demande une réaction du
gouvernement et interpelle également sur
la loi séparatisme alors quand il s'agit
de valeurs républicaines entre
guillemets la république en marche
contre attaque avec du gros calibre
insisté pas marlène schiappa qui a
répondu à la question de jordan barre
des lames et adeslas guérini en personne
le patron de la république en marche les
valeurs portées par la république en
marche ne sont pas compatibles avec le
port ostentatoire de signes religieux
sur un document de campagne électorale
soit ces candidats changent leur photo
soit la république en marche leur retire
à leur soutien
le message est plutôt clair un poil
tranchant et n'a pas manqué de choquer
certains marcheurs sur twitter les
piques et remontrances se sont
multipliés la députée du val d'oise
cécile relax voit avant tout une
provocation du rassemblement national
pour elle en aucun cas cette candidate
en frein à la loi républicaine
naïma mucho va plus loin dans ses propos
la vice présidente de la commission des
lois de l'assemblée nationale
le terme discrimination selon elle seuls
les électeurs décident les déclarations
percutantes mais la république en marche
ne change pas son fusil d épaule et
maintient sa position
juridiquement rien n'empêche une
personne de se présenter à une élection
avec un signe religieux mais je ne
souhaite pas présenté de candidat qui
s'affiche sur des documents officiels de
campagne avec un signe ostensible
religieux c'est une question de choix
politique quand on présente un candidat
à une élection
cela doit se faire dans un cadre de
neutralité alors stratégie électorale au
réel principes républicains telle est la
question les débats sont ouverts
l'union européenne s'attaque bel et bien
astrazeneca la commission a précisé son
action en justice une plainte pour
manquement à ses obligations de
livraison pour le deuxième trimestre le
laboratoire ne prévoit que deux livres
et que 70 millions sur les 180 millions
qu'ils avaient initialement promise
astrazeneca toujours dans la tourmente
au sein de l'ue la slovaquie à elle
suspendu mardi les vaccinations deux
premières doses après avoir annoncé
qu'elle examinait le cas d'un patient
décédé d'un caillot sanguin les
précisions avec walid bennani une longue
queue de plusieurs kilomètres au coeur
de cologne et une mosquée transformée en
centre de vaccination
astrazeneca le gouvernement fédéral
allemand a annoncé la levée des
priorités de catégorie d'âge pour avoir
accès aux vaccins anglo-suédois toute
personne de moins de 60 ans à savoir
toute personne majeure peut désormais
recevoir des doses excédentaires un coup
de publicité
logique pour le vaccin astrazeneca alors
que les campagnes de vaccination
s'accélère en europe bruxelles et
l'union européenne demandent d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui des comptes
en ces temps de crise sanitaire
économique l'hiver comme nous estimons
que l'entreprise n'a pas respecté les
termes et obligations du contrat ce qui
constitue une violation et nous
demandons aux tribunaux de la
reconnaître comme telle elle seule
en tout cas dans le cadre des procédures
d'urgence nous avons affirmé que nous
voulons que le tribunal ordonne à
l'entreprise de livrer 90 millions de
doses supplémentaires en plus des 30
millions déjà livrés au premier
trimestre des précisions prat une action
en justice lancée le 26 avril dernier
en cas de non respect d'obligation de la
part d'astrazeneca
la commission européenne demande le
règlement de pénalités financières
sur son site internet il ya deux
semaines le laboratoire botté en touche
toute critique en rappelant les
difficultés rencontrées pour la
fabrication d'un vaccin
astrazeneca regrette la décision de la
commission européenne d'engager une
action en justice concernant la
fourniture des vaccins coville 19 nous
pensons que tout litige est sans
fondement et nous nous réjouissons de
cette opportunité de résoudre ce
différend dès que possible une audience
en urgence aura lieu le 26 mai devant un
tribunal bruxellois
astrazeneca dans l'oeil du cyclone des
vaccinaux sceptiques avec notamment les
préoccupations liées à l'apparition
possible de caillots sanguins en france
comme dans d'autres pays du monde le
vaccin britannique au suédois reste
réservé aux plus de 55 ans au début du
mois de mai selon des chiffres du
ministère français de la défense
75% des doses disponibles d'astrazeneca
ont été injectés contre 90% pour le
vaccin finder biotech en dépit des
déclarations rassurantes du premier
ministre jean castex le gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron semble déjà tirer des
conclusions nous avons maintenant retour
d'expérience et d'ailleurs nous
vaccinons avec ce vaccin
en france et en europe il faut continuer
de le faire parce qu'il nous aidera à la
sortie de crise mais pour répondre en
particulier ou vario puisque l'on parle
d'une commande à venir pour répondre aux
variants on voit que d'autres vaccins
sont aujourd'hui plus efficaces donc
cela signe un pragmatisme européen et je
m'en félicite
le commissaire européen thierry breton a
indiqué que l'union européenne n'a pas
renouvelé
pour le moment sa commande de vaccins
astrazeneca
au delà de l'expiration du contrat fin
juin feuilleton à suivre au moyen de
rien présent des tensions dans le
détroit d'ormuz la marine américaine a
tiré des coups de semonce contre
plusieurs navires de guerre iraniens
selon le pentagone les bâtiments ce
serait trop rapproché d'un sous marin de
l'us navy basé dans la zone
l'iran de son côté dénoncent le
comportement de sites non professionnels
des états unis et des incidents qui
interviennent alors que la campagne pour
l'élection présidentielle iranienne du
18 juin bat son plein à téhéran le dépôt
des candidatures débute aujourd'hui
auprès du conseil des gardiens de la
constitution à san juan et déjà réélu en
2017 ne peut pas briguer de troisième
mandat et principaux enjeux de ce
scrutin le taux de participation est le
poids de l'armée alors que les
négociations sur le nucléaire se
poursuivent à l'échelle internationale
wade bénin
sourire en coin saïd mohammad est le
dernier candidat à s'être présenté
devant la presse samedi dernier les
journalistes nombreux et curieux à
l'idée de savoir si cet ancien membre
des gardiens de la révolution iranienne
a la carrure pour devenir le prochain
président de la république islamique
nous ne sommes liés à aucun mouvement
parti ou factions et nous ne nous sommes
assis avec personne et n'avons rien
promis notre gouvernement sera un
gouvernement de méritocratie
l'ex-général d'y être porté par les
demandes du guide suprême iranien
l'ayatollah ali khamenei
ce dernier souhaitant une transformation
de la génération dirigeante vieillissant
celle qui a participé à la fameuse
révolution de 1979 et oeuvrer à la
naissance de la république islamique en
iran toutes les candidatures sont
examinées puis validé par le conseil des
gardiens de la constitution nous sommes
aussi en train de passer un cap
générationnel de notre point de vue
l'entrée des jeunes dans le champ
politique est importante aussi et
peut-être la promesse de voir nos jeunes
entrés sur le terrain politique et jouer
un rôle à des niveaux élevés du pouvoir
exécutif
aujourd'hui plus d'une vingtaine de
personnalités publiques ont annoncé
officiellement leur candidature pour
briguer un mandat de quatre ans avec
l'ombre de l'armée qui plane plus que
jamais sur ces élections
outre seille de mohammad l'amiral rostam
ghasemi ancien ministre du pétrole a
aussi présenté son programme
présidentiel a ajouté le général hossein
d'art kahn ancien ministre de la défense
ou encore ezatollah zarghami ex membre
des gardiens de la révolution
une omniprésence militaire pointé du
doigt en coulisses par l'actuel ministre
iranien des affaires étrangères
critiqué par les conservateurs est
plongé dans une affaire d'état mohammad
javad zarif a présenté ses excuses sur
les réseaux sociaux
dans la foulée le guide suprême iranien
a préféré recentrer les débats al batha
baisse
massoudi n'est qu'un cheval et d'auzat
bien sûr on a entendu quelque chose de
la part de certains responsables du pays
qui fait qu'on s'interroge et qu'on
regrette vraiment il est à aso
nous avons entendu que les médias de
l'ennemi qui sont contre la république
islamique
les ont également diffusé m'ont relevé
on regrette quand on entend ces mots
certains de ces mots sur la répétition
des mots au style de nos ennemis
la répétition des mots des états unis en
afrique race monnayé au choix noir et en
blanc
la menace venant de l'occident au centre
également des élections présidentielles
et diplomates
mais le plus souvent ferme chaque
candidat s'est exprimé au sujet de
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien dans
les pourparlers reprennent vendredi
l'algérie se prépare aux élections
législatives anticipées voulues par le
président thé moon scrutin sur fond de
tensions économiques et sociales alors
beaucoup donc 2 alors que beaucoup
d'algériens sont engagés dans le lira
continue de battre le pavé tous les
vendredis pour demander une refonte
complète de l'appareil politique baisse
m shelly interrompu pendant plus d'un an
le irak a repris son cours sur
l'ensemble du pays ces dernières
semaines slogans et revendications
semblent tourner autour des prochaines
élections législatives
rejeté par beaucoup qui les considèrent
comme biaisée le vendredi est devenu le
symbole d'un rendez vous populaire pour
ces algériens bien décidé à renouer avec
une algérie plus libre et plus
démocratique
en réponse aux répressions policières de
ces dernières semaines des violences qui
inquiète au delà même des frontières
nationales l'onu ayant reçu des rapports
faisant état d' usage disproportionné de
la force ainsi que d'arrestations
arbitraires
nous demandons instamment aux autorités
algériennes de cesser de recourir à la
violence pour disperser les
manifestations pacifiques et de mettre
fin aux arrestations arbitraires et
détentions de personnes ayant exercé
leur droit à la liberté d'opinion
d'expression et de réunion pacifique
certains manifestants auraient été
détenus puis relâché après avoir été
contraint de signer un document
promettant de ne plus participer aux
manifestations
face à la détermination des manifestants
l'exécutif tente tant bien que mal de
garder le contrôle de la situation
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale
remaniement partiel du gouvernement ou
encore élections législatives anticipées
le gouvernement a tenté de multiples
gestes d'apaisement mais ceci ne semble
pas avoir trouvé d'écho auprès d'une
bonne partie de la population à
l'approché du scrutin les autorités
semblent vouloir équilibrer la scène
politique algérienne encore bien
imprégné des années bouteflika
principale force de contestation le irak
tente de faire barrage et d'entraîner
dans son sillage une nébuleuse de partis
d'opposition laïcs et comme de gauche
à l'image du rcd du pt ou encore de
l'upc tous regrettent ces élections
estimant qu'en l'état la tenue d'un
scrutin honnête et transparent est
impossible la place du rcd est aux côtés
du peuple mobilisent
et pour le changement du système et
l'avènement de l'alternative
démocratique et non dans le camp de ceux
qui répriment dans cette cacophonie
politique certains partis espèrent bien
tirer leur épingle du jeu et obtenir une
majorité au parlement
c'est le cas des partis islamistes à
l'image du mouvement pour la société de
la paix msp proche des mouvance des
frères musulmans qui considèrent que les
prochaines législatives seront empreinte
de transparence d'honnêteté et de
crédibilité entre l'irak et le
gouvernement le dialogue semble rompu
alors que la répression s'accroît dans
le pays selon les organisations de
défense des droits humains
face à la fronde populaire le
gouvernement algérien tente la carte de
la fermeté mais rappelle aussi est
compromis concédé parmi eux la
libération de la quasi totalité des
détenus du irak
la modification du code électoral pour
permettre la société civile de prendre
part au vote ou encore l'ouverture du
dialogue avec les partenaires sociaux
bien décidés à assurer la tenue de ces
législatives il surenchérit par la voix
d'un garde des sceaux au ton très
martiale les réponses ont été adaptées
aux menaces
la loi prévoit des peines
d'emprisonnement allant jusqu'à 20 ans
en cas d'atteinte au déroulement du
scrutin et troubles aux opérations de
vote alors que près de 1500 listes de
candidatures ont déjà été approuvés par
l'autorité nationale indépendante des
élections le scrutin du 11 juin
représente un pari difficile pour les
algériens qui vont devoir s'accorder sur
un consensus entre le irak
l'opposition et la société civile un
moyen peut-être pour le pays de sortir
enfin du traumatisme de l'après
bouteflika
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
a rendu son jugement sur les faire des
luxembourg l'x elle estime que la
justice luxembourgeoise n'a pas violé
les dispositions de la convention
européenne sur la liberté d'expression
en condamnant raphaël elle est une maman
lanceur dallaire dans la vaste affaire
d'évasion fiscale les juges européens
ont considéré que les documents
divulgués n'avait pas un intérêt
suffisant pour qu'il puisse être
acquitté pour rappel et luc slicks est
un scandale financier qui a concerné des
multinationales telles qu apple amazon
ou encore ikea et pour en parler nous
sommes avec fabrice epelboin enseignant
à sciences po spécialiste des réseaux
sociaux bonsoir fabrice epelboin merci
d'être avec nous
raphaël elle est donc un condamné pour
vol fraude informatique et blanchiment
justifié selon vous écoutez je n'ai pas
d'avis juridiques sur la question mais
d'un point de vue strictement éthique
non évidemment non la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme aurait dû protéger
les lanceurs d'alertés protéger
quelqu'un qui nous a révélé l'un des
plus grand scandale financier de
l'histoire de l'europe
un scandale qui explique beaucoup de
choses au sens où désormais on sait
pourquoi les grandes multinationales ne
paient pas d'impôts et cette inéquité
fiscale absolue que s'avère être
l'europe qui est pour les grandes
multinationales ta véritable paradis
fiscal contrairement aux petites
entreprises et aux citoyens et basse en
ce sens cet homme nous n'aurions pas
compris pourquoi nous l'aurions bien vu
mais ne l'aurions pas compris comment
tout cela s'organise et c'est très
regrettable que la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme n'est pas mis en
valeur cet homme et assurer une certaine
tranquillité aux futurs lanceurs
d'alerté car j'espère qu'il y en aura
beaucoup d'autres coachs comme cet
individu très justement c'est le message
que sept coureurs véhicules les lanceurs
d'alert maintenant doivent ils
s'inquiéter
si le statut qui les protège n'est plus
assurée non les lanceurs d'alerté
doivent s'adapter il ya des technologies
qui permettent à des anciens d'alert
d'envoyer des documents auprès de
journalistes sans révéler leur identité
en protégeant totalement leur identité
de plus en plus de médias les mettre en
place en france mediapart dispose d'un
tel système qui est si mes souvenirs
sont bons on s'appelle les frenchleaks
vous avez des associations de
journalistes qui disposent de tels
systèmes
vous avez un journal d'investigation
comme reflet pour l'info qui disposent
de tels systèmes donc il y à des
solutions technologiques à cette
défaillance de la protection du reddick
des lanceurs d'alerté qui permette
vraiment comme l'a inauguré wikileaks
était le premier à mettre en place et à
populariser ce genre de transmission
d'information entre une source et des
journalistes et en protégeant totalement
la source y compris des journalistes ou
de qui que ce soit qui reçoivent les
informations de cette source
ça veut dire vous êtes en train de dire
concrètement qu'il va falloir un petit
peu rusé par des moyens informatiques
pour être véritablement protégée c'est
bien ça puisque la justice n'a pas l'air
voilà de faire ce travail là en tout cas
même si elle juge certainement en droit
la justice n'est pas en mesure en france
comme un niveau européen de protéger les
gens c'est en alerte mais la bonne
nouvelle c'est que la technologie est en
mesure de le faire donc il ya des
solutions technologiques elles ne sont
pas bien compliquées il ya de plus en
plus de médias qui adoptent ce type de
solutions technologiques de façon à
pouvoir récupérer les informations de
ces sources qui souhaitent se protéger
donc ce n'est pas très grave dans
l'absolu la technologie va pallier à
cette carence de la justice vous dites
là je sais ce n'est pas en mesure de les
protéger
les juges appliquent à priori des lois
qui sont votées par le parlement sous
l'impulsion de l'exécutif est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il n'ya pas de volonté
politique en france de les protéger
en france on a eu la loi sapin qui est
un scandale à tous les niveaux et qui
sous prétexte de vouloir protéger les
ans soeur dallaire fait rigoureusement
l' inverse
le lanceur d alerte ne sont pas protégés
par la loi en france et l'ailé
les aspirants lancé en alerte français
ferait bien se renseigner sur ces
systèmes typiquement allez faire un tour
sur le site mediapart et regarder la
section qui est dédié à ce genre de te
de choses ou à les choisir une
association de journalistes qui
proposent ce genre d'interaction avec
des sources façon à les protéger
cc dans l'absolu c'est c'est décevant
vis-à-vis de la justice européenne
n mais ce n'est déjà six pas bien grave
ça ne changera pas grand chose
et pour ce qui est des lanceurs d alerte
ils peuvent toujours de façon secure
transmettre leurs informations à des
journalistes qui par la suite fort ou
des investigations sur la base de
documents tels que ceux de
pricewaterhousecoopers qui avait permis
de réaliser à quel point
l'évasion fiscale était généralisé dans
les grandes multinationales en europe et
à quel point l'europe effectivement pour
les grandes multinationales est un
paradis fiscal
merci beaucoup fabrice epelboin
enseignant à sciences po spécialiste des
réseaux sociaux d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france merci à vous et
c'est la fin de cette émission fait un
prochain point complet dans 10 minutes à
22h sur toute l'actualité de la journée
mercier
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez boxart y allons faire
connaissance
vous avez choisi le jour